The founding father of Greek philosophy, Socrates,...
...is portrayed in the dialogues of Plato...
...as hugely pessimistic about the whole business of democracy.
In book six of The Republic, Plato describes Socrates falling into...
...conversation with a character called Adeimantus...
...and trying to get him to see the flaws of democracy...
...by comparing a society to a ship.
"If you were heading out on a journey by sea," asked Socrates,...
..."who would you ideally want deciding who was in charge of the vessel?"
"Just anyone or people educated in the rules and demands of seafaring?"
"The latter, of course," says Adeimantus.
"So why then," responds Socrates, "do we keep thinking...
...that any old person should be fit to judge...
...who should be the ruler of a country?"
Socrates' point is that voting in an election is a skill...
...not a random intuition,...
...and like any skill, it needs to be taught systematically to people.
Letting the citizenry vote without an education...
...is as irresponsible as putting them in charge...
...of a trireme sailing to Samos in a storm.